now
is
just keep it clear
now
um
testing one two one two mic check
testing one two one two
okay thanks dude
thank you very much
foreign
okay
i
um
you are
oh
thank you
what do you do
properly
if dan got you master swag what would
you wear
i
left learn to do our stakeholders
i mean
okay
well luckily
i've never bumped into anything in my
life
no but i yeah i don't plan on staying
all the time
i figured
okay
doctor said
foreign
um
okay
i'm not yes
thank you
yes
how many speakers
um
is
thank you
are you guys participating
okay
good afternoon and thank you very much
for coming
uh this is a representative of our legal
team
we're representing president trump and
we're representing the trump campaign
uh when i finish uh
sydney powell and then and then jenna
ellis will follow me and we will present
in brief
the evidence that we've collected over
the last
i guess it is two weeks also uh joseph
the jennifer
victoria tends to get here with me there
are a lot more lawyers working on this
but where the
i guess where this where the senior
lawyers
and boris epstein so
i guess the best way to describe this is
when we began
uh our representation of the president
we
we certainly were confronted with a very
anomalous set of results
the president way ahead on election
night seven or eight hundred thousand
in pennsylvania somehow he lost
pennsylvania
we have statisticians willing to testify
that that's almost statistically
impossible to have happened in the
period of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation as
we started investigating
both our investigations and the very
patriotic and brave american citizens
that have come forward are uh
extraordinary extraordinary number of
people extraordinary number of witnesses
and what emerged very quickly is because
it's not a singular voter fraud
in one state this pattern repeats itself
in a number of states almost exactly the
same pattern
which to any experienced investigator
prosecutor would suggest that there was
a
a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter
fraud
specifically focused on big cities
and specifically focused on as you would
imagine
big cities controlled by democrats
and particularly focused on big cities
that have a long history of corruption
the number of voter fraud cases
in philadelphia could fill a library
just a few weeks ago there was a
conviction for voter fraud
and one two weeks before that and
i've often said i guess sarcastically
but it's true
the only surprise i would have found in
this is if philadelphia hadn't cheated
in this election because for the last 60
years
they've cheated in just about every
single election
you could say the same thing about
detroit each one of these cities are
cities that are controlled by democrats
which means they can get away with
anything they want to do
it means they have a certain degree of
control over
certainly control the election board
completely
and they control law enforcement and
unfortunately
they have some friendly judges that will
issue
ridiculously irrational opinions
just to come out in their favor so let's
start with the specifics
pennsylvania in pennsylvania
the margin of victory now for biden
which is a not a victory it's a fraud
is one hundred 69 forty votes
the reality is that we are now at a
count
of six hundred eighty two thousand seven
hundred and seventy ballots
for which we have affidavits that there
was no inspection
of that ballot at the time that it was
entered
in the vote it was a mail ballot mail
ballots are
particularly prone to fraud we were
warned about that by jimmy carter
president jimmy carter
and secretary baker in a report
about a dozen years ago in which they
said that mail balloting
is particularly uh susceptible of fraud
that we should very carefully consider
ever doing it
and that it can be taken advantage of
justice suiter warned us of the same
thing
in a comment in a election law case
and even the new york times wrote
articles
about how dangerous male voting
maryland voting was and um this is the
first time we ever did it on mass
and i think we proved that all three are
profits
it's not only susceptible to fraud it is
easily susceptible to fraud
particularly if you have a plan or
scheme
which sounds eerily similar to what joe
biden
told us a few days before the election
that he had the best voter fraud team
in the world well they were good
i don't know that they were that good
because they made significant mistakes
like all crooks do and we caught them
one of them was pushing out republican
inspectors
every state almost every
civilized country even tanzania and
places you wouldn't think of have
rules about inspectors particularly for
mail-in ballots
and why particularly for mail about
because they can more easily be
defrauded and you can't check on
people who have never done a mail-in
ballot i'm going to show you why
it's so easy well you fill out an
envelope
like this you put your usually in new
york would be yours your assembly
district
and the and the precinct in which you're
voting you fill out your name and your
address
and you sign it you then
use an inner envelope and you put the
ballot inside the inner envelope
you seal it all and you send it in when
it's being
and it's being counted almost invariably
in the united states
up until the mass cheating that went on
in this election
a republican and a democrat inspector as
well as others if there are other
parties
is allowed to watch the unsealing of
this ballot
used to go on all over america when we
conducted honest elections
because the only time you can ever find
out
if it's a fraudulent ballot is when it
is looked at
the minute you approve this it's thrown
away
gone for eternity the only thing left is
the vote
that could have been mickey mouse that
could have been a dead person
that could have been not filled out
properly that could have been
the same person 30 times that could have
been and all these things have happened
by the way
that could have been um nothing filled
out
we never know so for example the recount
being done in georgia
will tell us nothing because these
fraudulent ballots
will just be counted again because they
wouldn't supply the signatures
to match the ballots so it means nothing
to have counted these ballots because
for example in pennsylvania
where we have probably our most precise
evident 682
770 of these ballots were cast put in
and they weren't inspected
which renders them ballots that are null
and void
cannot be counted have to be removed
from the
from the vote uh why
for several reasons not the least of
which is
that was basically only one of two
places in the state where it was done
so in the other parts of the state there
was a legitimate
inspection of the ballots so if you have
two different standards in different
parts of the state
one favoring one part of the state the
other disfavoring the other part of the
state
that's a classic violation of the equal
protection clause of the united states
constitution
uh bush v gore being the most recent
case that
uh that that teaches that uh
that's not the only fraud that went on
in pennsylvania
all of the other frauds carried out in
the other states
by the democrat bosses
that happened there as well for example
if you made a mistake in that ballot
and you lived in philadelphia
or in pittsburgh you were allowed
to fix the mistake but if you lived in
the
what would be considered more republican
or trump
par parts of the state you were given no
such uh right
one of our plaintiffs mr henry cast a
absentee ballot
and he failed to put it
in the secure envelope
inside you just put it in open naked
that ballot was cast aside
because it was invalid because that
breaks the
privacy of the of the vote
in pittsburgh and
in philadelphia if they noticed that
there wasn't an inner envelope
they'd contact the voter and allow him
to vote again or if he didn't fill it
out completely
or if he made a mistake and didn't sign
his full name
he was allowed to cure it there is no
such provision under the law of
pennsylvania
the democrat secretary of state made
that up
in order to maximize the votes in
philadelphia and pittsburgh
and to minimize the votes in the other
parts of the state clearly illegal
clearly voter fraud easily provable
hundreds of witnesses maybe thousands
we have to give you another example
we have seventeen thousand provisional
ballots cast in pittsburgh
do you know what a provisional ballot is
provisional ballot usually happens this
way
and about 15 of the 17 000 happen this
way you walk in and you say
i'm here to vote today
oh mr giuliani you already voted i did
i don't remember voting oh yes yes you
cast an absentee ballot
no i didn't yes you did no i didn't yes
you did
so why does that happen 17 000 times in
pittsburgh
people walked in thinking they actually
15 000 to be
precise why did it happen 15 000 times
that people in pittsburgh walked in to
vote
and they had already voted
according to the democrat
election machine
did they forget that many people
with uh bad memories in pittsburgh
or is the following correct that
as witnesses will testify they were
instructed by the
democrat bosses when they had a ballot
in which there was no one registered
just assign it to somebody
just assign it to rudy giuliani so when
rudy julia and maybe rudy giuliani won't
show up to vote
and if he does show up to vote we'll
give him a provisional bout
that is what we call circumstantial
evidence of the fraud
the direct evidence of the fraud of the
people who will testify that in fact
that's what happened to them
as well as the 50
to 60 witnesses we have for the way they
were
treated and not allowed to inspect
the ballots they weren't just um not
allowed to do it
they were pushed a few cases they were
assaulted
in all cases they were put in a corral
so far away probably the closest they
got
is from here to the back of that room
we could do like a uh did you all watch
my cousin vinnie
you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies because he comes
from brooklyn
and when the the nice lady who said she
saw
and then he uh he says to her how many
fingers do i how many fingers do i got
up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie was from the witness
they couldn't see a thing now i don't
know
you're gonna tell me that 60 people are
lying
they they didn't just tell me this they
swore on the penalty of perjury
which is something no democrats ever
done
you don't even ask biden about this
you don't put him under penalty of
perjury he doesn't even get asked
questions about
he doesn't get asked questions about all
all the
evidence of the crimes that he committed
these people are under penalty of
perjury
their names are on an affidavit they
swear
that they weren't allowed to carry out
their function as inspectors
and it's not just a technical thing
there's a reason they did it
why would you not allow people
to carry out the function they've been
allowed to do for 50 years 60 years
why wouldn't you allow inspections of
those ballots
because you knew you were going to use
those ballots
to catch biden up
and you had a big road ahead of you you
had to catch him up for 700
000 to 800 000 votes that he was behind
and the only way you were going to do it
but with the mail-in ballots
you couldn't have a democrat and
republican inspector around
they don't even have democrats watching
it because they'd be afraid that they'd
be honest democrats who would say
you're cheating
so that takes us to michigan where there
was an honest democrat
who said they were cheating
and we'll show you her affidavit
because i know you keep reporting
falsely
that we have no evidence that we have no
specific acts of fraud
that's because the coverage of this has
been almost as dishonest as the scheme
itself
the american people are entitled to know
this you don't have a right to keep it
from them
you don't have a right to lie about it
and you are
i mean you don't report to them that a
citizen of this country
a very fine woman who is willing to
allow me to give
her uh give you her name
i can't give you all these affidavits
because if i do
these people will be harassed they'll be
threatened
they may lose their job they will lose
their friends
we've lost lawyers in this case because
they've been threatened
we've had lawyers that need protection
what's going on in this country is
horrible
and the censorship that you're imposing
is making it worse but
jesse jacob is an adult citizen and a
resident of the state of michigan
she's been an employee of the city of
detroit for decades
i know her age but
she can tell you her age she was um
she was assigned to uh voting duties
in september and she was trained by the
city of detroit
and the state of michigan she was
basically trained to cheat
she said that i was instructed by my
supervisor
to adjust the mailing date of these
absentee ballot packages
to be dated earlier than when they were
actually sent
in the supervisor made that announcement
for all workers
to engage in that fraudulent practice
that's not me saying that that's just
american citizens saying that
under oath i don't know
maybe you could say she's lying but you
can't say there's no evidence
this is what we call evidence this is
direct evidence
not circumstantial i tried many many
cases as did all my colleagues here
you put a witness on a witness stand
witnesses testifying to their own
knowledge
this witness goes on the witness stand
and she will say i was told to adjust
the date
on the absentee ballots i witnessed
election workers and employees going
over to the voting booth
with voters in order to watch them vote
and coach them for whom to vote
conclude she will testify to that
i don't know biden's people can
cross-examine her but you can't just
throw it away gee there's no evidence
next time you say that you'll be lying
because there is evidence this oh by the
way this is public you can all get it
it's attached to the complaint in
constantino versus the city of detroit
then she was instructed by my supervisor
not to ask for a driver's license or any
photo id
when a person was trying to vote
don't ask for an identification why
would you not ask for identification
because you knew that a lot of people
not entitled to vote
are going to come in an early vote
because you knew that illegal
immigrants were going to be allowed to
vote you knew
if you lived in philadelphia unless you
do not that's an italian expression for
stupid
unless you're stupid you knew that a lot
of people were coming over from camden
to vote
they do every year happens all the time
in philly
it's about as frequent as getting beaten
up at a philadelphia eagle basketball a
football game
happens all the time all the time
and is allowed to happen because it is a
democrat
corrupt city and has been for years
many many years and they carried it out
in places they could get away with it
they didn't carry it out in neutral
places they didn't carry it out in
republican places
they didn't carry it out where the law
is respected they carry it out in
corrupt
a corrupt city where the district
attorney releases criminals
on mass which is why it has so much
crime
she also said i observed a large number
of people
who came to the satellite location to
vote in person
but they had already applied for and
submitted an absentee ballot
so she observed a lot of people voting
twice
again this is
jesse jacob not me
i was instructed not to valid not to
invalidate any ballot
and not to look for any deficiency in
the ballot
why would you do that because you're
cheating
on purpose cheating intentionally
cheating
you're cheating as a institution this is
an instruction
from the election commissioner or the
the employer to the worker
don't look for any deficiencies in the
balance i was instructed not to look at
any of the signatures
the absentee ballots if she was
instructed
to look not to look for any of the
signatures on the absentee ballots
why the heck do you sign it in the first
place in order to identify it
she was instructed not to do that
because many of the absentee ballots
were fraudulent
and they knew that and they didn't want
to have a count to that
on november 4 2020 i was instructed to
improperly predate
the absentee ballots when the receipt
date
was actually november was was after
november 3rd 2020. now this is really
significant
because justice the leader of the
supreme court
instructed pennsylvania
that any ballot that comes in after 8
o'clock on november 3rd
2020 had to be put aside and not opened
because there's a question as to its
legality and its constitutionality
what she's telling you is that they
blatantly disregarded that order
that they took ballots that were marked
the fourth and the fifth
and the sixth and they marked it down
for the third
in blatant disregard of the order of the
united states supreme court
this is this is i don't know if she's a
democrat or republican
i assume if she's working if she's
working for the
i assume she's working with the city of
detroit that she's a democrat
i assume but i may be wrong she's a
citizen
i've i've never met her never coached
her
and i'd like you to note
that it's signed under penalties of
perjury
we have 100 more of these i can't show
them to you
because those people don't want to be
harassed they don't want to be
have their lives torn apart by the goons
on the other side we don't do that to
them
they've done that to a lot of our people
they've done it for four years and it's
outrageous
that it's tolerated and it's tolerated
because
you condone it in the press and you
don't cover it
and you don't condemn it and it
shouldn't happen to a republican or a
democrat
a lawyer shouldn't have to withdraw from
a case because he's representing the
president of the united states
there are many more affidavits here i'd
like to read them all to you but i don't
have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for them
that's your job like it's my job to
defend the president
and to represent the president it's your
job to read these things
and not falsely report that there's no
evidence do you know
you know how many affidavits we have in
the michigan case
220 affidavits they're not all public
but eight of them are
four affiants here those are people who
give affidavits
report an incident that under any other
circumstances
would have been on the front page of all
your newspapers if it didn't involve
the hatred that you have irrational
pathological hatred that you have
for the president what they
swear to is that at 4 30 in the morning
a truck pulled up to the detroit center
where they were
counting ballots the people thought it
was food
so they all ran to the truck wasn't food
it was thousands and thousands of
ballots
and the ballots were in garbage cans
they were in
paper bags they were in cardboard boxes
and they were taken into the center they
put on a number of tables
at that time they thought all the
republican inspectors had left
all but two had and an employee of
dominion
who uh we'll address a little bit later
dominion and here's what they jointly
swear to that every ballot that they
could see
every thing they could hear these were
ballots
for biden when they saw a ballot these
were ballots only for biden
meaning there was no down ticket just by
many of them didn't have anything on the
outer envelope
because these ballots were produced very
quickly very swiftly
and they're estimated to be a minimum of
60 000
maximum of a hundred thousand many of
them were
triple counted which means they were put
into the
counting machine this way once
twice three times
i didn't see that i don't know that but
for the fact that
three american citizens are willing to
swear to it
and we're not going to let them go to
court and do that
we're going to let this election go by
when there are
in this case 60 witnesses that can prove
what i'm saying to you and other acts of
fraud in michigan
i mean what's happened to this country
if we're going to let that happen
what happened to this country we're
going to cover that up we let al gore
carry on
an election dispute longer than this one
has been going on
for one state and for chad's
this happened in pennsylvania it
happened in
michigan michigan probably right now
if i count up the affidavits just one
case alone trump v
benson a case that we dismissed today
because
that case was attempting to get the
wayne county board of supervisors
to decertify well they did they
decertified
that case has a hundred affidavits
and the hundred affidavits show
essentially
what i've talked to you about
counting ballots improperly counting
them three and four times
uh having people having people vote
three and four times
changing and back dating ballots to the
point of at least
three hundred thousand illegitimate
ballots
that we can specifically identify the
margin in michigan was 146
121 and these ballots were all cast
basically in detroit
that biden won 80 20. so you see it
changes the results
of the of the election in in michigan if
you take out wayne county
so it's a very significant case that is
being raised in the case of constantino
versus the city of detroit not by us but
by an individual plaintiff
we are helping and assisting in that
case however
and you can find all the affidavits that
you want
filed in that case and you can find out
they're not just allegations
they're allegations supported by sworn
testimony
which is a lot better than joe biden has
ever done on anything he doesn't answer
questions
much less give you a small affidavit
wisconsin
wisconsin had a very small margin 21
20 544 last time i looked
in wisconsin without going into great
detail
very similar plan a republican
shutout in the city of milwaukee and
also in madison
republicans almost uniformly shut out
from the absentee
process not allowed to inspect not
allowed to look at the ballots
we have in milwaukee and in the state of
wisconsin
a much stricter law wisconsin doesn't
allow
mail-in ballots they didn't buy into the
big mail-in ballot
situation wisconsin
when you look at their constitution
almost seems to not like absentee
ballots
they state it's not a right a privilege
and they have
very very strict procedures and
the strict procedure says that you can't
be given an absentee ballot
you have to personally apply for it it's
illegal
basically to solicit a vote and they
have actually
many reasons for it it probably goes
back to their their
progressive days when i say progressive
i mean
late 19th century early 20th century
progressive
when that really meant progresses not
retrogresses
so there are 60 000 ballots
in milwaukee county and 40 000
ballots in madison that
as far as we can tell and this is why
we've we're auditing
because we have very good information
the numbers are going to come out about
here
that don't have applications under the
law of the state of wisconsin
already decided if there's no
application
for an absentee ballot the absentee
ballot is thrown away
this all happened in two places in
wisconsin
didn't happen in northern wisconsin
didn't happen in
republican wisconsin it didn't happen in
neutral wisconsin whether an equal
number of republicans and democrats
it happened in a place where the vote
was 75
80 percent for the democrat
you take away any number of those and
that 20 000
lead disappears in other words if you
count the lawful votes
trump won wisconsin by a good margin
indeed if you count the lawful votes in
pennsylvania
he wanted by about 300 000 votes
also in the in the lawsuit filed in
wisconsin which is really a petition
because of their
uh procedures there were no no
inspectors provided for the count of the
illegal ballots
there were numerous back dated ballots
we're just counting them now
run over into the thousands and there
were many precincts in which there was
an overvote
now let me explain to you what an
overvote is which is something you
should have explained to the american
people
because it's about the clearest
circumstantial evidence of massive fraud
that you can have
an overvote is if 200
of the people who are registered in the
district vote
think about that 200 percent of the
registered voters
in the district vote what does that mean
that means somebody voted twice
that means somebody who's not entitled
to vote voted
an illegal a person from another city or
state
a president is not registered
but what it means is that those are
illegitimate votes
you don't have an overvote of 200 or 300
you don't have an overvote of 100 most
most
uh precincts don't have 100 turnout
in fact classically it's considered to
be an overvote if you go over 80
well in michigan and wisconsin
we have over votes in numerous precincts
of 150 percent 200 percent
and 300 percent one of the reasons why
the two republicans did not certify in
wayne michigan
wayne county michigan is because the
overvote was so high
monstrously high in about two-thirds of
the precincts
in the city of detroit which means
magically
two and three times the number of
registered voters turned out to vote
in fact we have precincts in which two
times the number of people who live
there
including children voted
that's absurd
the frustration of this is what i'm
describing to you is a massive
fraud it isn't a little teeny one
it isn't you know 100 votes switched
here or there
georgia we're about to file a major
lawsuit in georgia
that'll be filed probably tomorrow i
don't need to go through it
virtually the same things i've told you
before very
in the city of atlanta
republicans were not allowed to watch
the absentee
mail-in ballot process inspections
completely cast aside and
we have numerous double voters we have
numerous
out-of-state voters and we have
specific evidence of intimidation and
changes of vote
that'll all be in the lawsuit that comes
out tomorrow arizona
is okay as a state that we're looking at
very very carefully
i would say we're probably going to
bring a lawsuit in arizona
more than probably i think we are going
to bring a lawsuit in arizona we're
still collecting that evidence
and the state that we're looking at that
would surprise you is
we have very very significant amount of
fraud allegations
in the state of new mexico which
and we have a significant number of
allegations in the state of virginia
i don't know yet whether the number in
virginia will reach the number that can
turn
uh the election in the states that we
have indicated in red
georgia pennsylvania michigan wisconsin
nevada and arizona we more than double
the number of votes needed to overturn
the election in terms of
provable illegal ballots all you got to
do
to find out if i'm misleading you at all
is to look at the lawsuits look what's
alleged look at the affidavits
maybe we can supply more affidavits in
order to do it i have to get permission
from the people
but in the materials i have here there
are at least 10
that come for citizens we have to out we
have a thousand at least
and we're getting more every day and
there are other aspects of this fraud
that at this point i really can't reveal
this is really enough it's enough to
overturn any election
it's disgraceful what happened and i'll
conclude by asking you to just think
about this for a minute
what happened on the morning of november
3rd when they were going to count
the these this new kind of ballot this
mail inbound
did every democrat leader
in pennsylvania and in michigan
and in wisconsin and in georgia and in
nevada
and in arizona they all wake up and all
separately
have the same idea do they all
separately have the idea
that we are going to we're going to put
republican inspectors in pens
we're not going to let them look at
mail-in or absentee ballots
they all independently come up with that
like
just by coincidence they say hey you
know we're gonna put
we're gonna put the republicans in pens
and corrals
we're gonna do it in pittsburgh we're
doing in philadelphia we're gonna do it
in detroit
we're gonna do it in milwaukee we're
gonna do it in las vegas
i'm gonna do it in phoenix what did i
miss oh we can do in atlanta
or isn't the logical conclusion
that i think any jury would accept as
they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan maybe that
was always the plan
to do these this very very questionable
form of voting
which has been criticized by president
carter
by secretary baker by most experts on
election reform
i think the logical conclusion is this
is a
common plan a common scheme it comes
right directly from the democrat party
and it comes from the candidate clearly
that's the reason why hillary clinton
said don't concede
even if you're losing that's the reason
we had a freudian slip by the candidate
and he said he had the
best voter fraud team in the country
that's the reason why he probably didn't
have to go out and campaign
he had to have known what they were
going to do this had to be planned in
advance
i'm kind of checking did they go you
know to the same
contract to get the corrals to put the
republicans in
and this is a disgraceful thing that was
done in this country
probably not much more disgraceful than
the things these people did in office
which you didn't and don't bother to
cover and you concealed from the
american people
but we let this happen you know we use
largely of venezuelan voting machine
in essence to count our vote we let this
happen we're going to become venezuela
we cannot let this happen to us we
cannot
not allow these crooks because that's
what they are
to steal an election from the american
people they elected donald trump
they didn't elect joe biden joe biden
is in the lead because of the fraudulent
ballot
the illegal ballots that were produced
and that were allowed to be used after
the election
was over give us an opportunity to prove
it in court
and we will now i'm going to ask
sidney powell to describe to you
what we can describe about another
totally outrageous situation i don't
think
most americans know that our ballots get
calculated
many of them outside the united states
and are completely open to hacking
completely open to change and
it's being done by a company that
specializes
in voter fraud i'll let sydney describe
that to you
thank you rudy
what we are really dealing with here and
uncovering more by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money through venezuela
cuba and likely china and the
interference
with our elections here in the united
states
the dominion voting systems the
smartmatic
technology software and the software
that goes in
other computerized voting systems here
as well
not just dominion were created in
billions
in venezuela at the direction of hugo
chavez to make sure he never lost an
election
after one constitutional referendum came
out the way he did not want it to come
out
we have one very strong witness who has
explained how it all works
his affidavit is attached to the
pleadings of lynn wood
and the lawsuit he filed in georgia
it is a stunning detailed affidavit
because he was with hugo chavez while
he was being briefed on how it worked he
was with hugo
chavez when he saw it operate to make
sure the election came out his way
that was the express purpose for
creating this software
he has seen it operate and as soon as he
saw
the multiple states shut down the
voting at the on the night of the
election
he knew the same thing was happening
here that that was what had gone on
now the software itself was created with
so many variables and so many
back doors that can be hooked up to the
internet or a thumb drive stuck in it or
whatever
but one of its most characteristic
features is is its ability to flip
votes it can set and run an algorithm
that probably ran all over the country
to take a certain percentage of votes
from president trump and flip them to
president biden
which we might never have uncovered had
the votes for president trump not been
so
overwhelming in so many of these states
that it broke
the algorithm that had been plugged into
the system
and that's what caused them to have to
shut down in the states they shut down
in that's when they came in the back
door with all the mail-in
mail-in ballots many of which they had
actually fabricated
some were on pristine paper with
identically
matching perfect circle dots
for mr biden others were
shoved in in batches they're always put
in a certain number of batches and
people would rerun the same batch
this corresponds to our statistical
evidence that shows incredible spikes
in the vote counts at particular times
and that corresponds to
eyewitness testimony of numerous people
who have come forward
and said they saw the ballots come in
the back door at that time
notably the dominion executives
have are nowhere to be found now they
are moving their offices
overnight to different places their
office in toronto was shared with one of
the soros entities
one of the leaders of the dominion
project in overall is
lord malek brown mr soros number two
person
in the uk and part of his organization
there are ties of the dominion
leadership
to the clinton foundation and to other
known politicians in this country
just to give you a brief description of
how this worked
i'm going to quote from a
a letter that was written and i will
read that to make sure i get the quotes
right
this person was objecting to the united
states acquisition
of sequoyah voting systems by smartmatic
a foreign-owned company
i believe this transaction raises
exactly the sort of foreign ownership
issues that cypheas is best positioned
to examine for national security
purposes
it's undisputed that smartmatic is
foreign owned and it is acquired sequoia
they keep changing the names as they go
along
different times when a problem comes up
they just create another corporation and
call it a different name
but it was a voting machine company
doing business in the united states
savoya sequoia voting machines were used
to record over 125 million votes
during the 2004 presidential election in
the united states
smartmatic now acknowledges that antonio
mujica a venezuelan businessman
has controlling interest in smartmatic
but the company has not revealed who all
the smartmatic owners are
according to the press smartmatics
owners are hidden through a web of
offshore private entities
and that is in fact true smartmatic has
been associated with the venezuelan
government led
by hugo chavez which is openly hostile
to the united states
and of course as we all know communistic
and
really brutalizing its own people the
system has been continued there
by mr maduro and ensured his election
smartmatic's possible connection to the
venezuelan government poses a potential
national security concern in the context
of its acquisition of sequoia
because electronic voting machines are
susceptible to tampering
and insiders are in the best position to
engage in such tampering
this letter expresses concern of the
chicago 2000 2006 primary election
and it ends by saying the the products
and services that are
venezuelan origin and evaluate
smartmatics ownership to determine
who could have influence and control
over these and other sequoia products
and services
are important to the national security
of the united states
this letter was written to hank paulson
on october 6
2006 by congresswoman carolyn b
maloney congress
senators klobuchar and
warren have raised these concerns as
recently as december
2019 why our government has not taken
them seriously
is beyond my comprehension unless they
have some of
the three-letter agencies have used them
themselves
in other parts of the world we know that
the technology was exported to
affect an election in argentina that's
admitted by
our friend who wrote the affidavit about
hugo chavez and his interest in
smartmatic
again in 2006 uh carolyn maloney wrote
the honorable john snow the secretary of
the treasury about the issues
speaking of smartmatics leadership
one of the smartmatic patent holders
eric
coomer i believe his name is is on the
web
as being recorded in a conversation with
antifa
members saying that he had the election
rigged for mr biden nothing to worry
about here and he was going to
they were going to f trump
his social media is filled with hatred
for the president
and for the united states of america as
a whole
as are the social media accounts of many
other smartmatic
people there has been widespread use of
this
dominion itself is utilized in 2000
jurisdictions in 30 states
it has been uncertifiable in multiple
states who realized all the problems
that it had including texas
experts have described it across the
board from a print
princeton group of three professors to
experts that we have talked to about its
end user vulnerabilities
people can admittedly go in and change
whatever they want they can set the
ratio of votes from one thing to another
they can say that
abiding vote counts as 1.25 and a trump
vote counts as 0.75
and those may be the numbers that were
actually used here
it's not just the swing states that were
affected the algorithm was likely run
across the country to affect the entire
election
like i said we only discovered it this
year because
of the overwhelming number of votes
for president trump in the swing states
that caused the machines to have to shut
down
for them to backfill for adding votes
we have evidence of different numbers of
votes being injected into the system the
same
identical unique six-digit number
multiple times in at least two states
that we've analyzed so far and i'm
talking about like
341 542 votes
for biden and 100 0012 for trump
there's no explanation no logical
explanation for the same numbers being
injected
20 minutes apart into the machine
the software manual itself you can
download it from the internet
and i would encourage you all to read it
because it specifically advertises some
of these things as features
of the system why it was ever allowed
into this country is beyond my
comprehension
and why nobody has dealt with it is
absolutely appalling
the machines were easily accessible to
hackers there's video on the net that
will explain to you how a kid with a
cell phone can hack one of these voting
machines
there's been no oversight of dominion or
its software
workers in each county were trained by
dominion but there's no
evidence of any monitoring otherwise we
have testimony of different workers
admitting
that they were trained how to dispose of
trump votes
and add to biden votes the software has
a feature pursuant to which you can drag
and drop
any number of batches of votes to the
candidate of your choice or simply throw
them away
so we have mathematical evidence in a
number of states of massive quantities
of trump votes being trashed
just simply put in the trash like you
would on your computer with any file
and biden votes being injected
that's addition to the flipping i mean
it really happens in two ways there's an
algorithm that
runs that automatically flips all the
votes and then each operator has the
ability to go in
override settings they can ignore a
signature they can ignore the
the top line of the ballot they can go
down ballot and select who they want to
change the results for
mr um
the gentleman who founded smartmatic
there's video of him on the internet
explaining that yes at least uh one
occasion he admits they changed a
million votes
with no problem many of the
jurisdictions that have had this problem
might not have known of the issues
but many did and i think a
full-scale criminal investigation needs
to be undertaken immediately
by the department of justice and by
every state's
equivalent attorney general's office or
state investigatory unit
because there are there's evidence of
different benefits being provided to the
people who spent
100 million dollars of taxpayer money at
the last minute
for their state to get the dominion
voting systems put in in time for this
election
in different ways there's one person
that a lawyer told me got quote election
insurance
meaning that he would be able to make
sure he was elected
i'm sure they explained that feature in
detail to
many people who expressed interest in
putting this voting system in
texas denied certification of the
dominion system in 2019
but there are no doubt issues with the
software that texas did use unbeknownst
to texas i would imagine
since they went to great trouble to
examine the dominion systems and reject
them
but other software in the source code
that does the alterations is embedded
we've been told
in the source code all across the
country and all the voting machines
there's no doubt it has been used to
alter elections in other countries
we know specifically that venezuela
exported it for that purpose to
argentina
and other latin american companies to
make sure that the corrupt rulers who
were willing to pay the highest price
for being in office were allowed to
rig their elections this is stunning
heartbreaking infuriating
and the most unpatriotic
acts i can even imagine
for people in this country to have
participated in
in any way shape or form and i want the
american public to know right now
that we will not be intimidated american
patriots are
fed up with the corruption from the
local level to the
highest level of our government and we
are going
to take this country back we are not
going to be intimidated we are not going
to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom
how come you're not suing in the
wisconsin counties that use this
excuse me that we're not out to the
questions at this point um
so excuse me we're not at the questions
at this point my name is jenna ellis and
i'm the senior legal advisor
uh to the trump campaign and i'd like to
just explain now
where we've been and where we're at and
what you can expect from this process
so what you have heard i'm sure in the
fake newspapers tomorrow will be one of
two things
either there was not sufficient evidence
that we've presented or
we spoke too long okay so what you've
heard
now isn't basically an opening statement
this
is what you can expect to see when we
get to court
to actually have a full trial on the
merits to actually
show this evidence in court and prove
our case this is not a law order episode
where everything is neatly wrapped up in
60 minutes
for those of you who are here in this
room or have maybe tuned out
in other networks clearly you've never
been court reporters
trials take time putting on evidence
takes time this is basically an opening
statement so the american people can
understand
what the networks have been hiding and
what they refuse to cover
because all of your fake news headlines
are dancing around
the merits of this case and are trying
to delegitimize
what we are doing here let me be very
clear
that our objective is to make sure to
preserve and protect
election integrity president trump has
been saying from day one
that this is about maintaining free and
fair elections in this country
it is not about overturning an outcome
it is about making sure
that election integrity is preserved and
every american
should want that if every american is
not on board with that you have to ask
yourself
why and if your fake news network is not
covering this or allowing you to cover
it
fairly and accurately you should ask
yourself why
this is absolutely a legitimate legal
basis
we have been asked to provide
an entire case that generally would take
years
in civil litigation i've been a
prosecutor i have tried cases
with far simpler facts one thing
happened
in a matter of minutes and it still
takes days and we go through a jury
process
this is the court of public opinion
right now we are not trying our case in
the court of public opinion
because if we were we would get unbiased
jurors i would strike
99 of you from the jury and i would be
allowed to
because of the fake news coverage you
provide you are not
unbiased jurors and until you step out
of your role as a journalist and
actually
go into a courtroom and you are a judge
on a bench
that has sworn an oath to be unbiased in
our separation of powers
then your opinion does not matter the
facts matter
the truth matters and if you are fair
reporters
you will cover that fairly and
appropriately and you will allow
coverage
of our media team here and our legal
team
that is absolutely shocking that all you
cover are around the margins
and i've seen all of you taking pictures
right now and i can
anticipate what your headlines are going
to be if you
are not willing to talk about the
evidence that has been presented
then that is absolutely unacceptable for
journalistic standards
this is an opening statement this is
something where we have told you what
the evidence will
show and we have given you a brief
description
that happens in a courtroom all the time
where that's not
the fact-finding process that is just an
overview
that is what we have given you today
because the american people deserve to
know what we have uncovered
in the last couple of weeks remember
this is such a
short time frame and this is an elite
strike force team that is working on
behalf of the president and the campaign
to make sure that our constitution is
protected we are a nation
of rules not a nation of rulers
there is not someone that just gets to
pick who the next president is outside
the will of the american people
and that is our task because when we
talk about voter fraud
it's actually election official fraud
that cannot stand the constitution
requires
that the state legislatures are the ones
that make election law it still has to
go
by the u.s constitution but what has
happened in this case
is that state and local level officials
and
all the way up have changed the rules
that's what the democrats do if they
don't like the rules
they change them they change them at the
last minute they manipulate them they
want to tear down our american system
our founders were so brilliant that they
anticipated this that there would be
corruption
there would be foreign influence there
would be attempts to manipulate the
outcome of the election
especially with who they called our
chief magistrate
i would encourage all of you to go home
and actually read alexander hamilton's
federalist 68 and see
what he described as an advocacy
position
to adopt and ratify
the electoral college and the process by
which we select our president
we select our president through the
electoral college not because it
disenfranchises voters but because it is
a security mechanism for exactly the
type of corruption
that we are uncovering and every
american should be grateful and thankful
that our founders had the foresight
to put in those protections and
provisions to make sure that
your legitimate legal vote is not
disenfranchised
that is what we are advocating for we
want to make sure to protect election
integrity
and your president president trump we
are so proud that he is in this fight
because he understands that when he
swore his oath of office
he swore an oath to uphold and defend
the united states constitution
that is what he is doing and that is
what we are doing we are confident
that through this multiple pathway to
victory we will get
to the actual outcome that the evidence
shows
but this is not about overturning an
election on our part
it's about making sure that we protect
and preserve free and fair elections
for all future american elections if the
united states caves to corruption
or this type of election integrity
disaster then no election will be secure
from here on out and we all need
to be keenly aware of that we are the
representatives
here that are standing in this gap and
defending
president trump and defending you the
american people at the end of the day
this is ultimately about the united
states of america
and we want to make sure to protect and
defend that and as my colleagues have
said
we will not back down we won't be
intimidated president trump will not be
intimidated
you the american people should not be
intimidated you the press
should cover this fairly and should know
that this
matters to election integrity and it
matters to the future of our nation
so we have given you an overview but
recognize this is not a court of law
we will get there and we have time and
we have constitutional provisions that
will step
in when we show the corruption and the
irredeemably
challenged and overturned votes
that are absolutely corrupt in all of
these counties
it is irredeemably compromised we will
show that
but you have to give us that opportunity
this has been just our opening statement
and we have an opportunity to get there
and we have time
and we will do that this is the united
states of america and we stand proudly
for president donald j trump
thank you
the world is watching this i have gotten
multiple emails from people in other
countries
who watch the same pattern happen there
we have witnessed testimony
that the same things were done in those
countries
as this was exported from venezuela and
by maduro
and by mr chavez and by cuba
and of course we know china also has a
substantial presence in venezuela and
substantial interest
in making sure that president trump does
not continue
in office this is the consummate
foreign interference in our election in
the most
criminal way you can possibly imagine
it must be shut down we know for example
that one of the dominion's highest
level employees or officers went to
detroit himself
to man the detroit operations center
where he could watch the votes coming in
real time
and decide what file folder in the
system to put those votes into
that's why you see massive spikes after
hours when people were told
that all the votes were in and all the
votes were counted
many dominion employees have already
reached out to us to tell us the truth
they are americans who want to ensure
election and integrity like we do
i would encourage every dominion or
smartmatic employee
who is fed up with the corruption in
this country to come forward as soon as
possible
because these are serious federal
offenses that i am confident the
department of justice
will be in pursuit of in very short
order if they are not already
all right a few questions yeah um mayor
giuliani uh this sort of reminds us 30
years ago
they had federal judges doing consent
decrees over elections so you had a
federal judge overseeing
uh the election
will you be asking that in georgia where
you have two the two senate races
have the u.s district court judges and
federal authorities monitoring the
elections
i i can't say what's going to be done
about that we have sort of a um
operation
i really can't give you an opinion on
that uh i think
obviously every election official should
learn something
from this and be very very careful with
the next election
i know this is a lot of information that
we've given you
probably because we're frustrated with
what we keep reading and hearing in the
censored press which is that we have no
evidence
we have no specifics we have no backup
of what we're saying
and you largely ignore the affidavits
that are filed
whether you agree or disagree with an
affidavit
it's evidence you can't say i mean
you're just
lying to the american people when you
say there's no evidence
sydney was giving you information that
come from affidavits from other people
that are given under oath i was
explaining things to you from affidavits
that come from other people american
citizens
who swear under oath that they saw one
hundred thousand
ballots come in and that they were all
for joe biden
and that i should point out now that
sydney has spoken
that those happened just around the time
that the dominion or smartmatic
people call the hall to the election and
then you can also
trace it with a very big spike in the
vote count at exactly that time
right up so what we're telling you is
supported by evidence
and we're going to have to present these
because of the procedures that exist
according to the different voting laws
of the different states for example you
asked us about
wisconsin we have to first create a
contest in wisconsin
before we can move to bringing a
fulsome federal lawsuit the contest
from everything i can see is going to
overturn the vote
because it's going to show somewhere
around 100 000 illegal ballots
in two counties that biden carried by
75 80 and you know how close wisconsin
is
and what i'm talking about is the
absentee ballots
for which there were no applications and
that's not just a small matter
the reason for the application and the
reason to keep
all these things together is precisely
to avoid
what the democrats did in this election
which is to misuse the absentee ballot
process and the mailing
process in order to cheat so they really
cheated in two respects
they cheated with the machines
it instead of asking me are we going to
bring a lawsuit in
wisconsin which we will if we have to
you should have asked me
and you should be more astounded by the
fact that our votes are counted
in germany and in spain
by a company owned by affiliates
of chavez and maduro did you ever
believe that was true
did any of you here believe that that
was possible
of course it's not of course it
shouldn't be possible
i don't know if we're going to have time
to develop all that
in time to fill the requirements of all
these cases
we have enough evidence without that to
overturn this election we have it from
the affidavits of american citizens
but that's a matter of national security
that we're talking about now
very very serious matter of national
security please don't make light of it
and don't act like you knew it don't act
like it isn't a surprise if that's not a
headline tomorrow
then you don't know what a headline is
there isn't a single person in this
country
that would have believed that we have
states that are stupid enough
to have our vote sent out of this
country
there's you couldn't possibly believe
that
the company counting our vote with
control
over our vote is owned by two
venezuelans
who were allies of chavez are present
allies of maduro
with a company whose chairman
is a close associate and business
partner of george soros
the biggest donor to the democrat party
the biggest donor to antifa
and the biggest donor of black lives
matter my goodness
what do we have to do to get you to
give our people the truth
name is liz willis with yes some on this
legal team
have mentioned before that people close
to the trump campaign are pressuring
them to drop the investigation into
dominion can you go further to detail
tell us specifically who those people
are also if it's possible can you tell
us if they
work with some of our powerful distances
in the united states such as the cia
the last part was do they work
with defense groups and the cia first
i've
i'm in charge of this investigation with
sydney and
the people you see here uh there's been
no pressure
to stop investigating dominion in fact
this
no there's pressure to go go as fast as
we can i mean i think there was
uniform shock when we first heard it i
think when i first heard it i didn't
believe it until sydney showed me the
documents
and in fact i feel kind of stupid in
your wall should because
all you had to do is go online and find
out that smartmatic
is owned by venezuelans close to chavez
you can google it well unless they take
it down i preserved it
so you can find it not you know and and
by the way
the coomer character who is close to
antifa
took off all of his social media
ha ha but we kept it we've got it the
man is a vicious
vicious man he wrote horrible things
about the president
he is completely he is completely biased
he's completely warped
and he specifically says that they're
going to fix this election
i don't know what you need to wake you
up to do your job
and inform the american people whether
you like it or not
of the things they need to know this is
real
it is not made up it is not there's
nobody here
that engages in fantasies i've tried 100
cases
i prosecuted some of the most dangerous
criminals in the world
i know crimes i can smell them you don't
have to smell this one i can prove it to
you 18 different ways
i can prove to you that he won
pennsylvania by 300
000 votes i can prove to you that he won
michigan
by probably 50 000 votes
when i went to bed on election night he
was ahead
in all those states every single one of
those states how is it they all turned
around
every single one of them turned around
or is it more consistent there was a
plan to turn them around
and since there are witnesses who say
there was a plan to turn them around
and it's kind of begs credulity to say
that it all happened in every single
state
my goodness this is how you win cases in
a courtroom
[Music]
our goal here is to go around the iron
curtain of censorship
that what publication are you with
[Laughter]
it's to go around the outrageous
iron curtain of censorship and get facts
to the american people
that if you were a fair and honest
network you'd have been reporting for
the last two weeks
these are facts these are things that
actually
happen these people really wrote these
affidavits these affidavits are really
part of the public record
you're concealing them you're covering
them up and our
role here is to do your job because
you don't do it
thank you where is our fbi
and how they express any interest
where are you fbi nothing's happened as
a result
of it i don't know where the fbi has
been for the last three years
i have no idea where the fbi has been
for the last four years
explain to me how the fbi concealed
a memo in the hand
of brennan to obama
saying that hillary basically made up
the russian collusion plot they they've
withheld that for
four years and cost our country 40
million dollars
and two impeachment one attempted one
actual
and then an acquittal proceeding i don't
know where they've been
i don't know where they were on the hard
drive they got it
eight ten months ago there are clear
crimes revealed on it
didn't do anything with that i don't
know where they are now our country
has had its ballots counted calculated
and manipulated
in a foreign country with a company
controlled
by friends of an enemy united states
what do we have to do to get the fbi to
wake up
maybe we need a new agency to protect us
i have no
just a minute in idea of the level of
corruption we are looking at here
we have no idea how many republican or
democratic
candidates in any state across the
country
paid to have the system rigged to work
for them
these people didn't do this just to take
control they make
one heck of a lot of money off of it
think about the global interests behind
your own news organizations
think about the pressure being brought
to bear on
from the social media companies to shut
down free speech
on any challenge to the election this is
a massive
well-funded coordinated effort to
deprive we the people of the united
states
of our most fundamental right under the
constitution
to preserve this republic that we all
cherish
it is of the greatest concern it is the
it is the 1775 of
of our generation and and beyond
yes tabulated overseas there's reports
that
there was a piece of hardware probably a
server picked up in germany
is that true and is it related to that
that is true
it is somehow related to this but i do
not know whether good guys got it or bad
guys
i can only hear one person at the time
i'm going to take the one with the hands
raised
yes um so question for you
first on the issue of the machine do you
plan to have
are you speaking in court order to
either fees or subpoena or just
to gain access to any of these machines
in any of these contested districts
have you begun that process uh and one
can expect a timeline on that
and then for you mr mayor you mentioned
in wisconsin and in michigan
these issues are overloading um where
can we learn more about this you're
saying 150 200
up to 350 in some places
where would we get access to that data
and then to what extent were
those uh people who showed up to vote in
person
because in michigan for example they did
allow same day registration
yes well the same day registration
causes problems with the vote signature
and the registration itself that's a
whole different
system that makes it impossible really
to validate the signature i mean one
person could sign
the same name i mean i mean i could sign
john smith i could sign kay smith i
could sign
you know both things and run 50 ballots
that way
and we've got some evidence of that
being done as well
um rudy do you want to speak to the
other party sure
we have now um three overvote
uh analysis done one for pennsylvania
one for
michigan and one for wisconsin
we're in the process oh i'm sorry
georgia we're in the process of doing
the others uh i'll check to see if it's
um
appropriate for us to make it public
well i imagine it is but you could
actually do it
yeah you could do it yourself a lot of
the analysis comes from the real time
data that came through to the news
medias
the the night and following the election
and some
inter entrepreneurs out there have
started crunching data themselves in
addition to multiple experts who could
easily recognize
with the mathematical brain that i do
not have
the the beyond explicable deviations
to the point of mathematical
impossibility that 186
000 votes come in at once all for joe
biden that's like flipping a coin
186 000 times and it lands on the same
it lands on heads every time that does
not happen
there is no reasonable explanation for
the
up shoots the straight lines up i'm not
even talking about a
an angle i'm talking about some massive
straight lines up
in the vote tallies in the middle of the
night after they've supposedly stopped
counting
and that's when the dominion operators
went in
and injected votes and changed the whole
system and it affects
boats around the country around the
world
and all kinds of massive interests
of globalist dictators corporations
you name it everybody's against us
except president trump
and we the people of the united
is the country states for this i mean
americans should be astonished
what you're saying here today is the
country on the verge of an electoral
breakdown
we've already had it we have already had
that electoral breakdown
but the constitution as jenna explains
has provisions in it
for how you fix this and there should
never be another election
conducted in this country i don't care
if it's for local dog catcher
using a dominion machine and smartmatic
software
we've got to have an american company
that uses paper ballots that we can all
verify so every one of us can see
that our vote is our vote why are you
not requesting recounts in wisconsin
county
this case is not only about remember
this case didn't begin with dominion
this case began and this case can be
proven the old-fashioned way
it can be proven based on just good
old-fashioned
democratic tactics that go back to mayor
daley
in the 1960s when he held the vote back
in chicago so that he could elect john f
kennedy
or as recently as last year when they
held the vote back
in palm beach county and broward county
in order to see if they could steal that
election for the senate and governor
and then got caught manufacturing
ballots democrats have been doing this
for years on a small scale
when they passed when they passed the
mail in voters
statute which all of a sudden
multiplied by 10 times the number of
mail-in votes
they realized they could have a field
day they could do precisely
what jimmy carter and uh secretary baker
warned us about all you all you have to
do
is own an election board and you can get
away with it
and unlike what sydney is talking about
where you can have a paper trail a paper
ballot
i tried to point out to you the minute
that you separate
the outer envelope from the ballot you
can no longer trace it
which is why the count whatever the
count in georgia today is
is totally ridiculous they're counting
the same fraudulent ballots
one more time and we're still very
how would close describe his mood at the
moment and do you and him still
genuinely believe you can
overturn this election or is it about
something bigger
well it's about something let's go
from the big picture to the smaller
picture
the most important thing here is that
this has been a
massive attack on the integrity of the
voting system
and the greatest democracy on earth the
people who did this
have committed one of the worst crimes
that i've ever that i've
i've ever seen or observed one of the
things we're the most
proud of in this country is that we've
been such a long-standing democracy
based on the right to vote they have
trashed the right to vote they've
dishonored the right to vote they've
destroyed the right to vote
and they agreed for power and money and
there's no doubt about it
this was not an individual idea of 10 or
12 democrat bosses
this is a plan you would have to be a
fool not to realize that
they do the same thing in exactly the
same way in 10
big democrat controlled in most cases
crooked city and when i say crooked city
go look at how many of their officials
have gone to jail in the last 20
or 30 or 40 or 50 or 60 years
that they have dominated and destroyed
those cities
they picked the places where they could
get away with it they picked the places
where whether or not republicans
testified to something
judges would just dismiss it because
judges are appointed politically
and too many of them are hacked they
pick places where
they could get a sheriff that refused to
to enforce a court order
when we got a court order that we could
be 10 feet closer
our representatives were told if you try
to do it i'll rescue you
part one part one it began as a national
conspiracy clearly that evidence emerged
very very quickly
the minute i saw that it was the same
thing in 10 states
just using logic i said this can't be an
accident
and then when i what i was surprised
about is the dimension of it
i mean not inspecting almost 700
000 ballots is astounding
honestly i don't know what joe biden is
aware of or not aware of
and i mean that as a lawyer not trying
to be
not trying to be cute i've watched him
i've observed him
um i honestly don't know how much he's
aware i don't know how much he decides
and how much things are decided for so i
i i i
just one other thing to your question
about the process
your question is fundamentally flawed
when you're asking where is the evidence
you clearly don't understand the legal
process what we have asked for in the
court
is to not have the certification
of false results and so to say hold on a
minute
we have evidence that we will present to
the court
we haven't had the opportunity yet to
present that
to the court we're giving you an
overview and a preview of what we've
discovered
but no court yet has has had we've had
that opportunity
so when we have a we've had and we have
fraud allegations
pending so what we've asked for are
temporary restraining orders
or injunctions to not certify false
results we're very happy that michigan
why the reason we dismissed
that lawsuit today is because the
michigan uh county in wayne county
they're not going to certify that
because 71 percent
of counties have inconsistent data no
person
in this room or in this country should
want states to rush through and
coordinate
a president with false results we have
to make sure
that the results are accurate that's
what we will prove two more questions
secretary of state where yeah my other
problems in michigan follow the money
follow the political party man i mean
you're actually seriously gonna
want me to take seriously the secretary
of state of michigan
when michigan when when when michigan
when the secretary of state of michigan
never bothered to find out
that the votes in her state were being
counted being counted
in germany by a venezuelan company
and you want me to take her seriously or
him seriously
mean i was i was in government
if i were the governor of that state i'd
fire everybody that was involved in this
election
they didn't come and tell me that my
state was going to be embarrassed
made a fool of because i'm sending my
votes of people in michigan
over to germany to be counted by a
company
that is owned by people who are allies
of maduro
and chavez by the way carolyn maloney
who wrote that is my congresswoman
a democrat pointed that out they didn't
do
the darndest bit of of due diligence
if you bought a 10 million dollar
company you would have done more due
diligence
due diligence than that maybe they're
incompetent
or maybe they didn't want to know but
you're not going to have me take
seriously
anything that comes from anyone involved
in the election the way it was conducted
in michigan
the secretary of state can say whatever
she wants to say of course she's going
to say that
she's a democrat she could also credit
the affidavits of the two people and say
that the board is tied and therefore the
vote hasn't been certified
so because she's a democrat she's saying
that
do you think she has any credibility
having run the kind of election they ran
in michigan
you think anyone in that government has
credibility after using a machine
and fooling their citizens there can't
be a person in michigan who thought
their vote was being sent outside the
united states
so somebody could play with it i mean
it's disgraceful what the government of
michigan did to its citizens
absolutely disgraceful last question
are you going to be able to get your
hands on
the sorry the voting machines or the
servers and
are you going to be able to see what
we are limited in what we can do we're
not the fbi
we're not the government we don't have
that kind of subpoena power
we don't have the power to just go
subpoena anything we want the government
does
uh we would have to subpoena in line
with a
case our first case we're asking for
that
authority in pennsylvania and in
michigan
but you have to get that authority from
the court we're private citizens we're
not the government
if if i were the government like i used
to be
they'd probably be a lot of people
arrested by now
because there's plenty of probable cause
plenty of probable
cause
[Music]
um we've seen that a lot of your
losses and in fact lawyers have been
kind of dropping
what fake network do you come from
completely independent oh my goodness
well first of all first first of all our
cases haven't been
dismissed we only have
[Music]
look at the plaintiffs it's not our case
man
don't lie to people ma'am
ma'am ma'am you are lying you're lying
you're lying oh continue to lie i'm not
getting
up ma'am ma'am
let me answer the question let me answer
the question
the answer to the question is we don't
have a lot of lawsuits we only have
three
our lawsuits have not been dropped all
over the place
okay well you're a totally discourteous
person i'm going to finish my answer
so i'm going to finish my answer the
fact is we have very very few lawsuits
the lawsuits you're talking about have
been brought by
private individuals and groups most of
them were dismissed for lack of standing
probably correctly because they were
brought before the election took place
the election is now over the only
lawsuit we have withdrawn is the one
where we got the relief that we wanted
and that's the one in
michigan we also have another lawsuit in
michigan that will accomplish the other
objectives of what we want to do in
michigan
so it's silly to have two competing
authors the only lawyer that
left a case left because he was
threatened his family was threatened his
children were threatened
and so was the other lawyer yeah that's
true we have a little difficulty getting
lawyers
because our lawyers get threatened with
being killed because of the
ridiculous way in which you cover this
and the ridiculous way in which you
cover
i'm not talking about you i'm talking
about everybody but i get a pretty good
sense
from the way you handle yourself how you
cover it all right we're finished with
you now
one last question one last question from
a
one last question one
last question one last question
from a reasonable civil person you are
not yes i'm not a reasonable person
no her she isn't well we'll find out oh
there we go
we're not going to drag it out i mean
it's ridiculous for you to say we're
dragging it out
al gore al gore had a lot more time than
we've had
and we've had two weeks to investigate
so that's also
completely unfair to say we're dragging
it out also if we're going to present
things in court if we present it to you
judges are not going to be very happy
with us and finally i have to tell you
our witnesses don't want to be exposed
to the tender mercies of a vicious press
i have great difficulty getting those
witnesses that i did reveal
to allow me to do it they don't trust
you they don't like you
they think you put their lives in
jeopardy with the spin that you put on
what's going on here and with the
unfairness in which you cover it
it's not easy to reveal the things that
they tell me
the answer is i can't do it because i
can't
i can't put a witness's life in jeopardy
or a person who thinks there's life in
jeopardy
this woman tells me we have lawyers
dropping out of the case
we have lawyers dropping out of the case
because they're being threatened
with destruction of their careers
destruction of their livelihood in some
cases destruction of their lives
that comes about because of the
hysterical way in which you have covered
donald trump and his administration but
we're going to change all that
we're going to go to court we're going
to prove it in court i would love to
release all the information that i have
i would love to give it to you all
except most of you wouldn't cover it
a few of you would and then we'd have
half the american people probably
informed
the censorship that is going on in this
country right now
by big tech and by big media
is almost as dangerous as the election
fraud that we're revealing
maybe just as dangerous we're headed to
a very bad place
and it is not inappropriate that a
venezuelan company
counted our votes thank you
here we go